-Guys, and, finally,
it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ "WeTweet" ♪
♪ "WeTweet" ♪
-Now, welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that
we should post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you
five different tweets,
and we're all going to
vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You see them there?
I can judge by
the confusion, yep.
Alright, perfect.
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want.
I want you to have fun, okay?
We're gonna see
the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you have clickers, too?
-I got my clicker.
-Yep, I'm all done.
-You're clicked out.
Alright, here we go.
Whatever tweet gets
the most likes,
we will tweet it out
live on the show
so you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it.
It's a shared experience.
Okay, you guys ready for this?
Okay, the first tweet is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is good. The first tweet...
Hmm. Hmm. Lukewarm response.
-No, yeah, lukewarm.
-Lukewarm at best.
Yeah, people are already
done voting.
Immediately, they said, "No."
You can cast your votes,
thumbs up or thumbs down.
They know --
I feel like this one --
-I think they picked
thumbs down.
thumbs down on this one.
[ Drumroll ]
-I thumbs-upped it.
-You thumbs-upped it?
-Yeah.
-I did it just to --
I felt bad for it.
-You felt bad for
the tweet itself?
Oh, I see.
-Yeah. But the votes are in.
Let's see the results.
Here we go.
Oh, not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's actually not bad.
That's pretty good.
-Yeah, 135.
-"Let's get brunch," yeah.
11:00 a.m., yeah.
-Hammered, 11:00 a.m.
-Yeah, gotcha. Alright.
Oh, I like this one.
The next one is...
♪♪
It's one of the two.
-Just that little thing.
-It's one of the two.
Either -- I can't --
That thing spins,
you know I got to
spin on that thing.
Also, medical school.
It takes years.
Too much work for me.
Alright, let's see
the results on this one.
I think it's gonna go
pretty well.
Yeah!
-Oh!
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's good, 183.
-That's pretty good.
-Yeah, that might be
the winner, right there.
But we have three more.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Let's see if you enjoy this one.
This next one's pretty good.
-Oh. Pithy, simple.
♪♪
-I voted -- Yeah.
-You say no? You voted down?
-I voted yes,
'cause I feel like --
Someone's very animated.
They're doing this.
It doesn't help.
-I like that, though.
Then you know they voted.
-And then I just saw an actual
human thumbs-down
from a -- A man in the audience
just gave me a thumbs-down.
Which he's been giving me all
monologue, by the way.
Let's see the results.
Alright. Okay. Wow.
-Ooh! Wow!
-They did not like that.
Steven Spielberg
asked for the "director's cut."
-Come on. That's pretty funny.
-It's pretty funny.
Yeah, that's good.
Next up, we have...
♪♪
"It's gonna be out,
and it's gonna be on."
"I can't even tell.
What is this?"
I can't --"
"Dad, you're blinding
half the restaurant."
Alright. There you go.
What do you
think about this, Tariq?
-Uh, yeah, I think it's probably
gonna be half and half.
-Half and half?
-You said it's gonna be evenly
split, yes or no.
-You think it's gonna be 50/50?
-I do. I do.
-That's impossible.
-That's insane.
-I do.
I think it's gonna be 50/50.
Fight me!
-No, he's saying 70/30.
-Okay, 70/30. I'll say 55/45.
-Oh, there you go!
-Oh! Now!
-It changed a little bit.
Let's check out
the results on this one.
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh!
Oh, snap! Oh, snap!
♪♪
Oh, my God!
Oh, my God! Oh, my God!
Tariq got burned.
-No, that's exactly
what I meant.
-You meant 195.
-That was almost
a knockout punch right there.
-Yeah.
-That's got to be the winner.
Everyone votes for
this one just because --
-195?
-It's almost unheard of.
That will be the one that we
tweet, unless this one --
unless this one is,
like, an avalanche.
-Is this the last one?
-This is the last one,
but I don't know.
[ Drumroll ]
What was the other one?
What did we all just like?
-"Phone on, light on."
-Which one?
-Dad with the light.
-Dad, menu, QR code.
-Oh, yeah. Dad, flash--
Yeah, we can all relate to that.
-It's more of a truism
and funny.
That's what makes it funny,
'cause it's kinda true.
-Yeah, I like that one.
-Yeah.
-That's a good one,
so let's see.
That, I think,
is gonna be the winner.
-I think it's the winner,
but who knows?
-Yep.
-We got one more.
-We have one more. Here we go.
-Tariq, what do you think
this one is gonna be?
-I think this last one's
the winner.
-Okay.
-Yep.
-Last one is...
♪♪
-Oh.
-Wow! That's a stealth one.
You're gonna vote no
just to burn --
just 'cause you like
the other one.
-You know you agree, man.
-Still moving.
-Thumbs up.
-Everyone agrees.
-I don't know, man.
I think "dad flashlight"
takes it.
-You know what?
You don't even want to
go to this one.
-I'm tired of being the peach
of your jokes over here.
-Let's see the results.
-Let's see it.
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh! Oh, my God!
-Yes. You felt that.
It did well. It did well.
"Dad's flashlight"
is the winner, right there.
So now I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a WeTweet, and enjoy.